ce soit ça me fait rire c'est trop tôt
parce que j'ai tellement pas leur garde
football un enfant avec avec la face
grassouillette puis oui je faisais 88
ling et je me serais quatrième saison la
documenter gema au cas où je continue à
jouer exactement faso
bonjour et compte saskatchewan à
montréal puis derrien de rennes qui est
leur carrière qui était quand même un
gros bonhomme c'est un très bon athlète
d'un gars qui court vite et arrive en
courant cissé plaqué par derrière par
john bowman qui est un gros bonhomme p
moi j'arrive avec 20 verges de l'ain et
je frappe de plein fouet
en comptant tous les trois sur le côté
moi je me relève puis mêmes sensations
que j'ai souvent eu juste un peu mêlé
sauf que là servier pour un mitage de la
misère à comprendre les ajustements gcs
moment l'objet d'une commotion cérébrale
ah mais je suis pro je termine à partie
puis je me souviens m'être dit lula dans
une commotion
c'est pas vrai foot recommence à marquer
des plaqués cause de cela vous êtes bien
informé pourtant vous savez que c'est
dangereux que vous pouvez laisser votre
père vous quant à mal un genou un coût
d'1 épaules
on va tous aller voir le médecin parce
qu'on sait que ça serait pas tellement
la tête là on est conscient que des gens
se serait pas fait ce choix parce que tu
veux pas être dicté quelqu'un qui est
étiqueté et des commotions cérébrales
c'est la fin bientôt puis je voulais pas
pourquoi ce coup là vous a achevé parce
que vous avez plein d'après moi c'est la
culmination ce je m'attendais à voir un
plaqué spectaculaire mais la première
fois je me dis j'ai dû le ramasser mais
ça juste cogné ben normal c'est là que
ça marche mais c'est sûr que c'est
l'accumulation avec le coup de la
semaine d'avant avec les années passées
à votre avis vous aviez des coups à la
tête
combien de fois dans votre carrière une
commission ou peau d'un coup ce mercredi
c'était tellement déprimé moi je le
contact que j'ai eues j'étais affecté le
plus c'est à l'avant de la tête à droite
sa série
j'ai su après coup directement avec le
goûter motifs émotions jugement je me
suis auto médicamenté avec des pilules
antidouleur
j'en prenais beaucoup j'ai été j'ai une
période très très creuse très noir très
sombre avec des idées qui étaient pas
coûte je pouvais je t'ai pas moi même
j'ai encore le boulou je songe à fait un
retour c'est spécial juste après vous
dire que je suppose mais enfin je qui
joue je le réalise à quel point ces
remixes et un peu de bon sens mais c'est
pareil qu'est ce qui vous manque le plus
ce qui manque le plus c'est de frapper
de cogner quelqu'un avoir un casque
d'avoir deux pour me créer un match
devant le droit d'être un maniaque
pendant 4h30 temps parce que je peux
jouer le tamani revenait à présent de
mettre un cas ce matin dans l'île un
groupe de le ramasser de savoir si vous
venez de gagner mesures sociales et vous
êtes prêt à risquer l'avenir de votre
taille de votre cerveau pour continuer
peut-être mais pas dissipées mésentente